Um aber unsere technische Zeichnung zu vervollständigen,
brauchen wir noch die Rückansicht.
Dazu legen wir uns eine neue Zeichenfläche an.
Ich gehe jetzt auf das Menü Fenster, ganz runter,
alphabetisch geordnet, auf Zeichenfläche und da seht ihr,
man kann sich eine neue Zeichenfläche anlegen.
Einfach auf das Plus-Symbol klicken und schon haben wir eine
neue Zeichenfläche.
Für meine zweite Zeichenfläche brauche ich ähnliche Vorlagen
wie für meine erste Zeichenfläche.
Das heißt, ich würde mir jetzt das Format kopieren,
dann die Schablone für die Rückseite auch hochladen
und dann würde ich mir tatsächlich mein Vorderteil des
Roggers kopieren,
um dann mein Hinterteil nicht noch mal von Null auf anlegen
zu müssen.
Erinnere dich daran, wir haben die Ebenen gesperrt.
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt dein Format anwählen möchtest und
kopieren möchtest um es auf deine zweite Zeichenfläche zu
legen, dann musst du natürlich erstmal die Ebene,
also die erste Ebene auf der sich das Format befindet,
entsperren.
Gehe auf das Schlosssymbol, entsperre diese,
dann über Direktauswahl und dann die Option oder Alt-Taste
gedrückt halten, ziehst du dir dieses Format rüber.
Jetzt kannst du noch eintragen,
dass es sich hier einmal um das Vorderteil handelt und
einmal um das Rückteil.
Und jetzt kannst du die Ebene auch wieder entsperren.
Gehe jetzt auf deine zweite Ebene, Schablone oder Vorlage,
entsperre diese und lade dir die entsprechende Rückansicht
hoch.
Wenn du das getan hast,
sperrst du diese Ebene wieder und jetzt kannst du deine
dritte Ebene, also deine technische Zeichnung,
die Vorderansicht von deinem Rock einmal auswählen mit dem
Auswahlwerkzeug, über diesen ganzen Rock drüber ziehen,
damit auch alle Details mit ausgewählt sind und dann
kopierst du das Ganze und ziehst es rüber auf deine
Rückseite.
So jetzt schaust du ein bisschen, wie das positioniert ist,
ob das auch alles auf der entsprechenden Höhe ist.
Wenn nicht, passt du das jetzt noch ein bisschen an.
So und jetzt müssen wir eigentlich nur noch unser Vorderteil
in ein Rückteil umändern.
Wir brauchen jetzt nur diese obere Linie die wir im
Vorderteil für den Rücken gezeichnet haben,
zu löschen und auch die Absteppung,
denn die befindet sich jetzt nur innen und wir sehen
sie von außen nicht.
Und jetzt müssen wir nur noch den Bund den wir schon
gezeichnet haben, etwas verändern.
Das können wir jetzt über das Direktauswahlwerkzeug machen,
indem wir jetzt hier diese Linie markieren und dann einfach
die Tangente nach oben ziehen.
So das Ganze mache ich jetzt auch mit der anderen Seite vom
Bund und natürlich auch noch mit dem Rock
an sich.
Und jetzt merke ich,
dass die Abnäher nicht mehr an der richtigen Stelle sitzen
und dass eventuell auch vorne und hinten unterschiedliche
Anzahlen von Abnäher sind.
Das heißt, ich füge dann entsprechend Abnäher dazu oder
lösche sie und werde sie auch an der richtigen Stelle
positionieren.
Und hinten habe ich auch keine Taschen,
deswegen würde ich jetzt erstmal die Taschen auswählen,
zum Beispiel mit dem Auswahlwerkzeug und dann der
Shift-Taste, sodass ich gleich beide Taschen auswähle und
diese dann lösche.
Ein weiterer Unterschied ist,
dass es im Rücken oftmals eine Naht gibt auf der hinteren
Mitte und sich dort auch ein Reißverschluss befindet oder
auch ein Schlitz.
Das würde ich jetzt noch einzeichnen,
zum Beispiel mit dem Linienwerkzeug oder auch mit der
Zeichenfeder.
Für einen klassischen Rock ist es meistens so,
dass wir den Reißverschluss nicht sehen.
Das heißt, den würde ich vielleicht auch gar nicht
einzeichnen in der technischen Zeichnung,
außer vielleicht eine kleine Absteppung markieren.
Das könnte man zum Beispiel mit einer kleinen gestrichelten
Linie machen.
Das gleiche gilt auch für den Schlitz,
der sich unten befindet.
Hier eine kleine gestrichelte Linie,
um diesen Schlitz zu markieren.
Später kann ich das dann auch noch beschriften,
um wirklich zu zeigen,
wo genau ist jetzt mein Schlitz und wo genau ist mein
Reißverschluss.
Jetzt ist meine Zeichnung wirklich
fertig.
Was ich jetzt immer noch mache, ist,
dass ich die einzelnen Zeichnungen auch gruppiere.
Also einmal das Rückteil mit all seinen Details gruppieren
und das Vorderteil auch mit all seinen Details gruppieren.
Dazu wähle ich erstmal meine Zeichnung komplett aus und
jetzt mit dem Rechtsklick auf gruppieren drücken und
so habe ich wirklich meine Zeichnung ganz kompakt
beisammeln.
Und wenn ich diese jetzt bewegen möchte,
muss ich nicht immer alles einzeln auswählen,
sondern es ist alles in einem,
also auch mit den ganzen Details.
Jetzt möchte ich noch einmal die Unterschiede zwischen dem
Vorderteil und dem Rückteil für euch zusammenfassen.
Die Deswegen sieht man in der technischen Zeichnung ganz oft
auch das Rückteil, denn die hintere Mitte sitzt etwas höher.
Das ist bei Unterteilen und auch bei Oberteilen der Fall.
Vorder und Rückansicht noch einmal zusammengefasst.
Für Konturlinien einer technischen Zeichnung benutzt du eine
Punktstärke von einem Punkt und für die Details von 0,5
Punkt.
Wenn du die Form auswählst und gleichzeitig entweder Alt
oder Option, je nach System drückst,
kannst du eine Form ganz schnell kopieren.
Wenn du eine Form spiegeln möchtest,
gehst du auf den Kreis mit dem Pfeil und der kleinen Ecke da
runter, da befindet sich das Spiegeln-Werkzeug.
Wenn du eine Form zusammenfügen möchtest,
dann geht das über den Rechtsklick auf zusammenfügen
klicken.
Wenn du einen Punkt löschen möchtest,
geht es über die Zeichenfeder und dem Minuszeichen.
Für Absteppung benutzt du gestrichelte Linien.
Diese erstellst du über Eigenschaften, Kontur,
gestrichelte Linie und setzt hier die Punktstärke auf zwei
Punkte runter.
Hier nochmal die wichtigsten Punkte für
was man für eine technische Modezeichnung
benötigt.
Als erstes ist es wichtig,
dass du mit einer Schablone arbeitest,
wenn du maßgerechte Zeichnung haben möchtest.
Hierfür haben wir verschiedene Formate und Vorlagen für dich
vorbereitet.
Wenn du anfängst mit einer technischen Zeichnung,
beginnst du am besten an der Mittellinie und zeichnest
zunächst die Hälfte der technischen Zeichnung.
Dann lässt du an der Seite etwas Platz,
denn es ist ja eine technische Zeichnung,
die flach gezeichnet wird und du zeichnest zunächst
mit Hilfe von Linien und Kurven über das
Zeichenfederwerkzeug die Grundform.
Danach zeichnest du alle Details ein.
Wenn du dann die Hälfte deiner Form mit allen Details
gezeichnet hast, kannst du die Form spiegeln.
Du kopierst dafür die Form erst einmal und spiegelst sie
dann über das Spiegelnwerkzeug.
Dann setzt du beide Formen zusammen,
nebeneinander und fügst sie zusammen,
über Rechtsklick zusammenfügen.
Wenn deine Form dann zusammengefügt ist,
kopierst du das Ganze und zeichnest die
Rückansicht.
Zum Schluss nicht vergessen alle Zeichnungen zu kopieren.